movie has been a long time in the making
and you've had to go through a lot
because you wear many hats making this
film you're in it you're directing it
right at me this is incredible it's
incredible project the movies based on
you know loosely on your relationship
with sex is that fair to say yeah okay
and you grew up pretty fearful of sex is
that right
would you say yeah well I grew up
Catholic and I used to ya know yeah yeah
go ahead so you grew up and and so it
was maybe was it not discussed sex or
was it discussed it was not discussed I
mean I mean it was kind of discussed I
would watch TV and my dad and I would
watch The Love Boat and when there was a
scene where like a couple would go into
a room together and they kiss my dad
would say this couples about to have
premarital sex and you can go to hell
for that and that's wrong there is no
way to watch The Love Boat why is he
watching that show anyway would he say
that every time - cuz that's not even it
that's it's a family-friendly show
anytime two characters like left
together and went into a room and
romantic music played he would think
that that was did you ever see the movie
somewhere in time with Christopher Reeve
and Jane Seymour yeah I think so it's
very romantic so at the very end he
travels through time to be with her and
then they have a love scene at the very
end of the movie and my dad was like
what was wrong with that film they had
premarital sex and you can go to hell
for that what's wrong with that movies
that they traveled through time
that's the flock with that movie Wow
well okay you I'm I'm assuming you move
past this phase yes I did okay and you
know it's funny because I was raised in
a Catholic family one of six kids and so
there's a fair amount of you know
there's some repression there do you
have advice for people on moving past
the repression say people like me well
okay when I have at fears or problems I
try to do an affirmation and say the
opposite so I have it in my phone and I
write all these affirmations in my phone
like I approve of myself and I am
lovable so you could just go
I am so sexually amazing no I'm being
you know I'm just trying to tell you no
I would get halfway through that
sentence and start giggling you don't be
what makes you what makes your name by
the way you are right what makes you say
that just married a really long time
your wife's hot I looked it up today I'm
like please Conan's wife look like and
she's really hot
do you notice she's crying in every
photo I do have a very hot wife I'm very
yes yeah yeah
Wow this got weird fast I swear to God I
have no idea what I was gonna ask next
we were talking about Who I am really
good at sex and you can just tell that
you